[Music]  the peanut special it's the great  pumpkin charlie brown you all saw that  right  yeah  man  that's a halloween classic uh but some  people are complaining that the show is  too mean for today's children i've seen  a bunch of articles where they talk  about how if you look at it now it's too  mean yeah the kids are kind of hard on  each other yeah well you know it's funny  i didn't remember that i watched the  show though the other night with my kids  i got to admit it's meaner than i  remembered  you suck charlie brown  shut up douchebag  well look who's here mr ash  i hope you get kids or die  [Music]  i remember the rest i didn't remember  the grenade i just  no cause later he says i got a grenade